20 Rockets have been fired in southern
Israel in the past few minutes and
warning sirens have been sounding across
the region on Thursday one person was
killed in rejovard an Israeli city close
to Tel Aviv Israel has also carried out
airstrikes in the south of the Gaza
Strip in the last few hours at least 31
Palestinians have been killed since the
attacks began on Tuesday let's go live
to villain Marx who's in Ashkelon in
southern Israel near the border with
Gaza tell us about what's been happening
in the last few minutes Rockets fired
into Israel film
yeah that's right but we can actually
hear some of them are slightly further
down the road here towards Gaza some of
them have been targeting a little
Community down there called Ash coal
maybe two or three kilometers south from
our position another couple of
kilometers further to Gaza itself we've
heard there have been siren sounding in
some of the various towns and small
communities close to where we are now
possibly around two dozen rockets in
total coming from Gaza and of course
overnight there were those strikes in
southern Gaza by the Israeli military
they said they were targeting concealed
rocket launchers and Military posts
involved in these efforts by Islamic
Jihad to launch what's been more than
800 Rockets over the course of this week
and what are Israeli authorities saying
to Residents there Willem
well they've been arguing that people
should either evacuate and in fact the
Israeli military is confirmed to us this
morning that they are in continuing with
those efforts to move people away from
some of these communities further south
of us here further north to get them
into areas that are less likely to come
under this heavy rocket fire we know
that schools in a number of the towns
and cities nearby have been closed for
today and essentially emergency measures
are in place until later today right now
million minutes Netanyahu is making a
security assessment I can hear a jet
overhead at the moment an indication
that further airstrikes will be striking
Gaza right now right above our head in
fact but Netanyahu himself he's been
involved in security assessments with
his top military and intelligence
officials over the course of the last
hour so that may again have a bearing on
how the Israeli military operates over
the the coming hours okay thank you for
the update villain marks live there in
Ashkelon and we'll come back to you for
the latest on that meeting the prime
minister is having Let's cross over to
Mohammed who is in occupies Jerusalem
Muhammad is joining us live from
Damascus Gates you've been speaking to
Palestinians who are there for Friday
prayers Muhammad tell us about what
they've been telling you about what's
happening in Gaza
before they first and foremost what
we're hearing from all those we spoke
with is how sad they are about the
reality on the ground for Palestinians
in Gaza everybody we've spoken with thus
far today has said the tragedy in all of
this is the fact that civilians continue
to be killed in these attacks especially
the fact that children continue to die
and be killed in these attacks as well
so they're very sad about that and they
say that's one reason why this all must
come to an end and why there needs to
eventually be a political solution for
what's going on in Gaza they say that
militarily nothing can be achieved
ultimately for residents of Gaza beyond
that what's interesting is to be getting
a little bit of a political analysis
from the the Palestinian worshipers who
are arriving here to attend Friday
prayer because many of them have talked
about
um what's going on when it comes to the
factions as far as from their point of
view uh inside of Gaza two men that we
spoke with had had essentially the same
opinion when it came to the role
potentially of Hamas and all this both
of them said they do not believe that
Hamas is involved in in retaliation for
the Israeli airstrike so one of them
said they believe that that's because
Hamas doesn't want to um doesn't want
their rival Islamic Jihad to get any
kind of Leverage and to gain any kind of
Advantage from all of this another
gentleman we spoke with said that Hamas
has its own reasons and he thinks that
they eventually will enter The Fray but
that they have not as of yet so mixed
reactions but agreement specifically on
the fact that the people who are
suffering the most are the civilians
inside of gospel and are any of the
people you spoke to optimistic Mohammed
about the prospects of a potential
ceasefire
Folly everybody we've spoken with today
said they do not believe that a
ceasefire will come into place anytime
soon most the folks we spoke with said
they believe it will be at least a few
more days of uh of of uh of airstrikes
inside Gaza and retaliatory rocket
strikes from Gaza toward Israel they say
certainly that's concerning but they
also said that they do believe that
everybody who's involved in this
conflict really does not want it to
escalate much more that right now it
will continue to play out this is
according to the people we're speaking
with that's what they believe but they
do think a ceasefire will come into
effect at some point they just don't
think it's going to happen anytime in
the next couple of days okay thank you
for that update Muhammad Jam live for us
here at Damascus skate in occupies
Jerusalem